este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a das
link
daschle en es una herramienta de
seguridad todo-en-uno que te permite
generar contraseñas seguras almacenar
las guardar tu información personal y de
pago guardar notas de forma segura
proteger tu privacidad todo de forma
rápida y precisa beatas link.com barra
visual polítiques y descárgate lo de
forma totalmente gratuita además usando
el código visual polític s podrás probar
la versión premium totalmente gratis
durante 30 días y luego si decides
continuar con ella tendrás un 10% de
descuento
[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos en el pasado mes de
abril de 2019 una encuesta provocó todo
un terremoto político en argentina un
terremoto que tuvo también importantes
consecuencias económicas veréis la
consultora isonomía una empresa cercana
ojo al gobierno lleva trabajando con
macri desde hace muchos años señaló que
si se produjera una segunda vuelta en
las próximas elecciones argentinas una
hipotética candidatura de cristina
fernández de kirchner superaría al
actual presidente mauricio macri
[Música]
la mala marcha de la economía está
haciendo que el apoyo al presidente
macri aguas por todas partes la
inflación por las nubes la subida de las
tarifas y la sensación de que cambio lo
que se dice cambio ha habido más bien
poco ha hecho que la popularidad de
mauricio macri se está desplomando más
rápido que el valor del bolívar
venezolano
[Música]
sin embargo amigos he esperado un
momento el pasado 18 de mayo un segundo
terremoto político sacudió la argentina
por primera vez en toda la historia una
candidata a vicepresidenta anunciaba a
su presidente no se puede cambiar un
país únicamente con un buen gobierno en
sus tres poderes para cambiar un país
hace falta un buen gobierno y una buena
sociedad si cristina fernández hacía
pública su decisión de presentarse a las
elecciones pero no como número uno sino
como número dos como candidata a la
vicepresidencia la ex presidenta
kirchner busca regresar al gobierno como
vicepresidenta tal cual como lo
escucháis finalmente el candidato
kirchnerista será alberto fernández jefe
de gabinete de néstor kirchner y durante
un año de la propia christina le he
pedido a alberto fernández que encabece
la fórmula que integraremos juntos él
como candidato a presidente y yo como
candidata vice para participar en las
próximas elecciones primarias abiertas
simultáneas y obligatorias cristina
fernández de kirchner amigos con este
nuevo
rama podemos hacernos al menos tres
preguntas la primera es fácil por qué
diantres ha tomado kirchner semejantes
decisión esto lleva tiempo esfuerzo
perseverar en los objetivos nadie puede
hacer las cosas en dos o tres años
la respuesta tiene mucho que ver con su
buen momento de popularidad como hemos
visto por primera vez desde el año 2015
varias encuestas situaban a kirchner
como ganadora no sólo en primera vuelta
sino también en segunda y de paso
dirigirme a todos amigos compañeros y
funcionarios que tengan algunos
bolsillos en plazo fijo donde usted
moreno no bueno
ahora bien un momento los mismos
pronósticos también señalaban un alto
número de indecisos y amigos los
expertos electorales lo tenían muy pero
que muy claro el miedo al regreso del
kirchnerismo llegadas las elecciones
podría movilizar muchos votos para el
oficialismo
sin embargo ahora con esta decisión
ocurre en otras dos cosas por un lado el
miedo a la expresidenta en cierto modo
se diluye no es cabeza de cartel y por
el otro el nuevo tándem puede llegar a
votantes a los que kirchner por si sola
nunca hubiera llegado
[Música]
veréis explico la candidatura de alberto
fernández
aparentemente pone sobre la mesa
regeneracionismo un discurso más
moderado y la idea de que luego también
aplicaría políticas diferentes a las de
los mandatos de christina de la señora k
algo imprescindible para lograr la
victoria claro a ver si quieres ganar
las elecciones no sólo puedes contar con
tus acérrimos por un lado hay que
convencer a más gente y por otro no
movilizar el voto de tu rival
[Música]
christina como vicepresidenta aporta
toda su fuerza electoral sin causar un
excesivo miedo así que bajo este
panorama la decisión tomada por la ex
presidenta multiplica sus opciones de
volver al poder y eso eso para ella es
lo más importante no sólo porque le
gusta el poder sino también porque lo
necesita
cristina fernández de kirchner tenía sí
o sí que participar en las elecciones
por su situación legal de la que ya os
hemos hablado aquí en visual político la
ex presidenta arrastra ni más ni menos
que diez procesamientos judiciales y
cinco peticiones de prisión preventiva
amigos si no está ya en la cárcel es
porque simple y llanamente aún mantiene
sus fueros como senadora el senado
dominado por los peronistas no se los ha
retirado y desde luego ser
vicepresidenta les supondría renovar los
fueros
bien la primera pregunta porque ha
decidido presentarse como vicepresidenta
queda contestado la segunda pregunta es
realmente este tándem puede ganar las
elecciones de verdad estamos hablando en
serio después de los malísimos
resultados de su anterior gobierno y de
toda la corrupción
amplían el procesamiento a cristina
kirchner en la causa de los cuadernos el
juez claudio bonadío la considera
coautora de otros cinco hechos de
cohecho y elevó el embargo en su contra
80 millones de pesos
pues si eso al menos es lo que se
desprende de los estudios de intención
de voto- encuestas como las de analía
del franco o ricardo rouvier y asociados
situaban a kirchner por delante con una
ventaja de 95 y 4 puntos respectivamente
también podemos encontrar encuestas
incluso más importantes donde macri iván
cabeza así pero con un margen cada vez
más pequeño y tal ahora con la nueva
fórmula muchos de los miedos al
kirchnerismo se diluyen entre otras
cosas porque el propio alberto fernández
fue muy crítico con la presidenta en el
último mandato de cristina es
dificilísimo encontrar a algo virtuoso
alberto fernández año 2015 llegó a decir
que alemania estaba peor que nosotros en
materia de pobreza sostuvo hasta el
final que el cepo no existía y que la
inflación no importaba eso es negación
una negación terca por momentos absurda
alberto fernández año 2015 es decir
ahora de la noche a la mañana la fórmula
integrada por kirchner se puede permitir
incluso
enarbolar la bandera del cambio algo así
como el aprendimos de nuestros errores
pero nuestras intenciones eran buenas
ahora estamos preparados y lo importante
no es el protagonismo de una persona
sino el proyecto increíble verdad
[Música]
claro que tampoco se puede decir que
este escenario sea una sorpresa o algo
excepcional para nada forma parte de una
tendencia
macri ha pasado de liderar las encuestas
en enero a empatar con christina en
marzo y a quedar bastante por detrás de
ella en abril por muy sorprendente que
nos pueda parecer el apoyo a christina
según todas las encuestas no ha parado
de subir la expresidenta ha pasado de
ser un dolor de cabeza para el peronismo
que quería renovarse a ser su mejor baza
para poder recuperar el gobierno de la
nación
[Música]
y es que hoy por hoy la evolución de la
economía parece que va a ser el factor
decisivo si las cosas no fueran muy mal
tal vez macri podría hacerse con el
apoyo de suficientes indecisos como para
mantenerse en la casa rosada- el
problema que tal y como están las cosas
parece complicado que la situación
económica se pueda mejorar en el corto
plazo y esa es la mejor baza hoy del
kirchnerismo un nuevo resbalón y envían
a macri de paseo la economía argentina
vive un momento muy pero que muy
delicado la inflación de marzo fue del
47 por ciento ojo la inflación de un mes
no la de todo el año 2019 puede cerrar
con una inflación de entre el 35 y el 50
por ciento el peso no deja de caer
respecto al dólar
las bolsas tampoco van nada pero que
nada bien el riesgo-país ha llegado a
rebasar los 1000 puntos y la economía
nacional sigue en recesión
amigos de visual política la carrera
entre macri y la hipotética candidatura
de kirchner se había convertido en algo
así como una carrera por lograr ser el
menos malo a ojos de la opinión pública
y no no es ninguna crítica son simple y
llanamente los datos
[Música]
tanto cristina fernández de kirchner
como mauricio macri cosechan una
valoración muy negativa entre los
argentinos en el caso del actual
presidente según las encuestas hasta el
84% de los argentinos tienen una opinión
negativa de él por su parte aunque
parezca mentira dados todos los
escándalos los datos de la ex presidenta
son algo mejores aunque tampoco mucho
mejores en su caso el porcentaje de
opiniones negativas sería del 76 por
ciento
[Música]
pero ahora con alberto fernández las
cosas son diferentes el nuevo candidato
está mucho menos manchado que la
expresidenta por cierto un paréntesis
crees que nuevos candidatos como josé
luis espert tienen posibilidades de
remontar las encuestas crees que sería
bueno para la argentina cuéntamelo en
los comentarios si yo no creo que
retroceder en lugar de cinco casilleros
con cristina presidente retroceder 15 ir
a una cosa parecida a néstor bajando la
cristina subiéndolo alberto fernández
signifique un cambio sustancial por el
economía y por el lobby de la gente no
me parece bien pero bien retomemos
tercera pregunta y visto lo visto la más
importante de todas y consecuencias
tendría la victoria de alberto fernández
y cristina fernández de kirchner y por
qué tipo de políticas públicas
apostarían
[Música]
para empezar a responder no tenemos ni
siquiera que esperar al mes de octubre
veréis el mero hecho de que kirchner se
convirtieran favorita las encuestas ya
puso muy pero que muy nerviosos a todos
los inversores internacionales bueno
mejor dicho aún más de lo que ya estaban
y eso se tradujo en un nuevo hundimiento
del peso frente al dólar
luego que puede que también haya
alimentado la idea de esta nueva fórmula
ahora bien por qué tanto nerviosismo
pues porque se daba por hecho que el
regreso de cristina al poder supondría
el regreso a las mismas políticas ultra
intervencionistas y de más y más gasto
público de la anterior etapa a ver
tampoco es que macri haya supuesto en
ningún gran cambio pero claro si
volviese christina cualquier posibilidad
de que argentina mirara el rumbo y no
digáis que no le hace falta tener el
rumbo argentina quedaría totalmente
descartada
[Música]
el caso es que el simple hecho de que la
sangre se pusiera a la cabeza en los
sondeos alimentó el miedo de los
inversores a un nuevo y próximo default
de argentina y amigos eso pone las cosas
aún peor hasta tal punto que incluso
algunos analistas como carlos malamud
han advertido de una próxima corrida
cambiaria esto es que se hunda aún más
del peso porque todo el mundo quiere
desprenderse de la divisa si el
kirchnerismo sigue mejorando sus
probabilidades de hacerse con el
gobierno en cualquier caso más allá de
si macri gana o pierde las elecciones lo
cierto es que la situación hoy de
argentina es complicada el gobierno
tendrá que devolver en 2020 la friolera
de 34 mil millones de dólares en un
contexto de recesión económica y con un
peso que se deprecia a toda velocidad
argentina está en una encrucijada su
deuda nominada en dólares es muy pero
que muy grande supone casi el 90 por
ciento del pib cifra que no para de
crecer como consecuencia del hundimiento
del peso cuanto más cae el peso mayor
carga supone en la deuda nominada en
dólares para la economía argentina
de que con uno u otro presidente
argentina y pague su deuda es hoy por
hoy elevado
ojo la probabilidad de 'default' es
elevada así pero no es un hecho
consumado la situación aún no es
irremediable y por fortuna parece que
casi todos los líderes políticos lo
tienen claro el hecho de que cristina
haya decidido postularse como
vicepresidenta en la candidatura de
alberto fernández podría ser una buena
prueba al fin y al cabo como ya hemos
visto alberto fernández fue muy crítico
con la gestión de cristina fernández
[Música]
claro que lo que argentina necesita es
un cambio de rumbo total y la verdad
tampoco parece que alberto fernández
quiera liderar ese cambio de la mano de
la ex vicepresidenta no os parece y eso
amigos es lo que nos lleva directamente
a las dos grandes preguntas de este
vídeo primero estará el nuevo gobierno
ya sea de macri fernández o cualquier
otro candidato dispuesto a llevar a cabo
este cambio de rumbo total contesta en
esta encuesta y segundo muy importante
te preocupa tu privacidad en la red si
es que si quédate conmigo unos segundos
más ya vivas en un rosario o buenos
aires con das line mantendrá su
identidad online de forma segura daschle
te protegerá de todo tipo de amenazas
contra tu identidad
hay muchos saqueos ahí fuera y la mejor
manera de esquivar los es utilizando
dust lane das link es una herramienta de
seguridad todo-en-uno que incluye una
vpn para todos tus dispositivos de tal
forma que puedas usar redes públicas de
manera segura y anónima también hacen
una cosa llamada monito
dark web y esto que es pues consiste en
escanear la web en busca de datos
personales filtrados o robados alertando
te al instante en caso de que tus datos
personales se encuentren donde no deben
tal forma que puedas tomar medidas
rápidamente
y por supuesto das le ayudará a generar
contraseñas seguras y cada vez que una
web te pide a introducir las que ayudará
a rellenar los campos requeridos de
forma rápida y sencilla es súper cómodo
como os decía antes das link es
totalmente gratuita pero hay algunas
opciones premium en caso de que quieras
disponer de más servicios bien pues si
entras en das link.com visual políti que
ese usando el código visual polític s
tendrás una prueba de estas opciones
premium totalmente gratis durante 30
días y si decides continuar con ellas
después obtendrás un 10% de descuento a
la hora de contratar las no lo dudes
entra en el link que te hemos dejado en
la descripción y descárgate estás link
de forma gratuita como siempre un saludo
y hasta la próxima
i
[Música]
ah